let's talk about the real reason why
your serotonin is low
and you may be depressed or have anxiety
okay now
most people know that serotonin is
involved with their mood
when you look this up in any medical
physiology book
they don't know exactly for sure what it
does but they do know it's related to
someone's mood changes so if there's a
problem with serotonin okay it can
really affect your mood behaviors and a
lot of other things okay
there are
also people who take ssris okay that
stands for selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors
basically they're medications
that allow you
to not absorb
serotonin and allow for more serotonin
to be used by your body okay because
normally you have these
uptake or
kind of receptors that absorb serotonin
once it's being released so it
inactivates serotonin if you inhibit
that you're going to have more serotonin
available these are medications and they
have side effects and let me just give
you my disclaimer right now
anything that i say check with your
doctor first before implementing okay
all this information is based on my
opinion and some of the studies down
below but there are some really bad side
effects with ssris number one suicide
thoughts and suicide actions
number two manic episodes you might have
excessive energy well that's actually
not too bad compared to the other side
effects but you also might have
excessive happiness which
again i don't know why someone would
have a problem with that but the main
side effect
is this and i'm going to pull this up
close to a hundred percent of people who
take antidepressants experience some
form of sexual side effects there's this
condition called post ssri sexual
dysfunction
and this is a really terrible thing
because it can cause genital numbness
almost to the effect that it feels like
someone is using an anesthetic or some
type of
nerve
deadening agent so basically your
genitals have no more feeling people
also experience zero libido
they feel kind of
wooden and a lack of emotion some people
don't experience the emotion of love
and others just get no pleasure from
erections or orgasms or
anything involved with the sexual act
not to mention erectile dysfunction the
problem is
that this could last for
decades okay now there's this other
thing that i found when i was looking at
this it's called discontinuation
syndrome now what is that
i mean this is basically just another
it's a nice name for withdrawals from
this poison i'm sorry medication now i
read an article on this which is
basically just disgusting i just have to
mention something because they were
taking these serious withdrawal symptoms
and turning into something that is you
know just normal it says discontinuation
and change are
a part of life
we all start and stop
various activities job changes
relationship changes
and so forth and many medical treatments
might have some side effects
as we navigate through our depression
and anxiety navigate through our
depression and anxiety
is that what people are trying to do no
they're trying to get rid of
depression and anxiety they just made
with serious withdrawal symptoms which
by the way is just terrible because
coming off these medications can
actually exaggerate these symptoms and
they could last for
decades
so that being said
why are people so deficient in serotonin
that's what i want to talk about right
now
plus percent of all the serotonin in
your body
is not actually made by your body it's
made by your good bacteria
in your gut so we are dependent on our
good bacteria for serotonin and a lot of
other things like our immune system
only a very tiny
percent of all the serotonin made in the
body is made by your brain okay
that's point zero zero zero zero zero
one that's one one millionth of all the
serotonin is made by your brain so you
could pretty much
look at that as virtually zero right the
majority of serotonin is made by
not our own bodies but
bacteria
so if anything goes wrong with our
serotonin can suffer greatly now i want
to introduce you to this
this word here called glyphosate okay
what is glyphosate that is a very
specific herbicide it's one of the most
common
herbicides weed killers that is just all
over the world right now almost every
chemical company makes it because the
patent ran out
and i want to just explain a little bit
about this okay
in 1960
it was discovered that this chemical
could be used as a descaling agent what
does that mean
basically it's a chemical that can bind
with a metal okay or a mineral like
manganese for example or zinc
so that was in 1960 and in 1969 they
found that it kills plants and then 1996
they came out with something called
roundup ready okay
and that's a herbicide that kills weeds
if you look up glyphosate roundup ready
you're going to see
a lot of mixed reviews
you're going to see positives you're
going to see negatives
and it's going to be very confusing
there's huge pr campaigns
to make it appear to be safe
and
basically what they say is that it's
safe because
it doesn't affect humans okay at least
how it affects plants and animals
because it blocks this very specific
pathway called the
shikimate pathway now this pathway
really involves enzymes enzymes are
proteins enzymes always have a metal or
mineral
as their base okay
and this sigma pathway has
manganese so glyphosate basically works
by binding with
manganese making this enzyme not work
anymore in bacteria in plants well guess
what's interesting about this
this specific enzyme okay makes
three
actually three to four but it's three
main
amino acids
tyrosine
phenylalanine
and
tryptophan okay tryptophan what is
tryptophan
and well you know maybe you've heard of
tryptophan as a supplement people take
it for um
for sleep
and mood
and to build up their serotonin because
serotonin comes from tryptophan you
can't make serotonin without
tryptophan
if you
block the production of tryptophan and
by the way tryptophan is an essential
amino acid that means that our body
can't make it
and we must get it from another source
so i found some fascinating research
relating to this chemical
and lowered tryptophan and lowered
serotonin amounts so even though our
bodies don't have this pathway
our microbiome is a huge part of our
health
and our immune system and our ability to
make neurotransmitters and you really
need to consider the microbiome as
another organ you know um a bushel of
corn
used to weigh
about 56 pounds okay in the past
now if you weigh a bushel of corn it's
54 pounds
so we're missing two pounds where is
that going well since the great majority
of corn is gmo
that means that it's been exposed to
glyphosate and this enzyme has been
deactivated because it's been bound with
manganese so basically this is two
pounds less because we're missing
two pounds of this metal or mineral
manganese which weighs about two pounds
per bushel so i believe this herbicide
is really behind
a problem with serotonin worldwide now
let's talk about what we can do about it
is there a strategy
this is what i'm going to recommend as a
strategy
immediately start eating organic foods
now does that mean that all organic
foods don't have traces of glyphosate no
but it does mean that it has less
glyphosate
and i don't want to go too far down into
that rabbit hole but non-gmo
does have less but
if you're looking at foods that have
organic versus non-gmo organic has less
glyphosate
the other thing i'm going to highly
recommend is if you're going to get
you know
meats
grass-fed grass finished because
these animals
consume grains that have been exposed to
glyphosates so if you can get actually
grass-fed grass-finished meats
that's going to help you not be exposed
to that herbicide as much and of course
you know also eggs you know get organic
pasture-raised eggs number two avoid the
most common foods that are heavily
sprayed with this glyphosate soy
corn wheat
and sugar
both beet sugar which is the majority in
the u.s
and also
sugar cane and of course the seed oils
canola cotton seed are heavily sprayed
not to mention the
soy oil the third thing
probiotic foods i'm not talking about
just taking a probiotic i'm talking
about fermented foods
sauerkraut kimchi
fermented vegetables kefir very
important because
if you have
sufficient microorganisms okay
you can to certain degree counter this
glyphosate effect so even though
virtually everyone has glyphosate in
their bodies it's all a matter of um
dosage and concentration in certain
amounts
so you want to have a very healthy gut
microbiome to counter
this exposure to living in this
environment number four increase the
amount of vegetables that you eat
because the fiber feeds the microbes
that's their food and if you have
a lot of different types of vegetables
you have a more diversified
microbiome and that can be very
beneficial to you okay so don't just
have one vegetable
over and over and over
number five get exposure to the sun not
to the point where you're burnt but get
regular exposure to the sun not only
will vitamin d help depression and
anxiety and but the infrared from the
sun
can increase
serotonin and melatonin okay i mean
think about in the winter why people get
depressed because they're the sun we're
not getting the sun exposure like we do
in the in the summer months
number six exercise exercise can
actually increase the conversion from
tryptophan to serotonin which is a very
good thing and also number seven
of course this is a given keto and
intermittent fasting both of these
actions
not only avoid
these type of cereal foods and grains
but ketones generally help your brain in
sodas intermittent fasting and it can
definitely increase your cognitive
function and your mood right off the bat
and number eight
on a regular basis apple cider vinegar
like a tablespoon in water now why
because
acetic acid bacteria are also greatly
affected by glyphosate which means
you'll make less acetic acid and acetic
acid
really uh is a major
small chain fatty acid that can affect
your ph in your gut and when the ph is
affected a lot of other problems can
happen so we want enough acetic acid in
our digestive system to keep the ph
correct and taking apple cider vinegar
could be one extra thing that can help
you since we're on the topic of
depression and anxiety if you haven't
seen this video related to nutritional
deficiencies
i think you'll enjoy it check it out